- [Voiceover] Oh my god,
Brandon's my best friend.
(laughs)
- Yes, Brandons, all Brandons,
they're like best friends.
- Yeah, they're super sweet people.
- I think Brian is a trustworthy name
and Ryan is a hot name.
- Ryan's like your friend, too.
- Nick is totally your friend's name.
- Yeah, it's like Nick is Nick.
I think Nick is very unoffensive.
- Nicks are a good name.
- Yeah, if your name's Nick, you're fine.
Everyone's gonna like you.
- I feel like Jacks, for
some reason I get a vibe
that they're gonna like swindle you
or they're the ones that
are gonna cheat on you.
- Red flag name: T.J., R.J.
- Josh is a red flag.
- R.J., T.J., P.J.
- No, Jacob's a creep.
- Jacob's stupid.
- Don't do this with Jacob again.
- Yeah (laughs).
- (mumbling)
- Anybody who goes by their last name.
- That's my favorite!
- David.
- David's a powerful guy name,
like Michael, classic names.
- William.
- Oh yeah, especially if
they do the whole name.
- I feel like Liams are business guys.
I see them suited up.
- If you have a friend, a girlfriend
that you're concerned
about, and she tells you
she's starting to date a William,
it's kind of one of those
things where it's like--
- It's gonna be okay.
- She's gonna be okay.
- The name that I am
most likely to be like
a guy who's kind of gross is Adam.
- Oh, I love the name Adam!
- Adams are like I finger-banged
someone in the bathroom
and didn't wash my hands.
- Bob.
- I also could never say
Bob and be serious about it.
I could never be in a fight with someone
and be like come on, Bob!
- Steve, oh, it sounds like a nerd.
It's tough to be a Steve.
- Frank, I think Frank is
not a good looking guy.
- See, here's the thing, the name Frank
is kind of like whatever,
but then I happen to know
some really hot Franks.
- Really?
- Do I?
- I would love to say that
I ended up with a Dylan.
- I would love to date a Brandon.
- Of course you would!
- I've always wanted to date a James.
- Ethan, ooh.
- Surfer boy.
- Totally.
- Ethan, you like Ethan.
- I love Ethan.
- I like Ethan, Ethans are confident.
- Just smoking hot, has
this amazing sense of humor.
- Ooh, I love Jake, Jake
is my favorite male name.
- Jake is rugged.
- Yeah.
- Jake is like the heartthrob.
- Very fit, very cool.
- He's got the nicest five
o'clock shadow you've ever seen.
- I think Parker is a hot name.
- Parker is so sexy.
- Have you ever met a Parker?
- No.
- Oh.
- Maybe that's why it's sexy.
- I know, yeah.